bienvenue dans cette suite de l'été
consacré à l'économie
cette année on a beaucoup parlé de la
hausse du chômage de la crise économique
rien de bien réjouissant mais le monde
de l'entreprise ne se limite pas à ça ou
vous a préparé une petite sélection de
reportages réalisés cette année pour
vous prouver qu entreprise peut rimer
avec plaisir dans la deuxième partie de
ce magazine nous parlerons des jobs
d'été
vous verrez que dans le département les
étudiants peuvent travailler ailleurs
que dans l'animation
allez on commence tout de suite avec
quelques reportages sur le bien-être des
salariés
depuis huit ans les vergers de gally
livre des fruits dans les entreprises un
concept qui marche plutôt bien
regardez ce reportage réalisé par
valérie auribeau et elodie moines
comme tous les matins sébastien parent
avec la liste des clients a livré dans
son camion
les corbeilles de fruits qu'il faut
préparer selon chaque commande
nous livrons des paniers de fruits dans
l'entreprise et les entreprises peuvent
les utiliser soit par le principe d'un
abonnement donc sur une période
déterminée soit par le principe si vous
voulez du one shot de l'événement un
conseil d'administration une réunion
commerciale ou une soirée entre
collaborateurs peuvent être aussi
l'occasion de partager des fruits frais
ce jour là sébastien commence la tournée
chez un client régulier
le constructeur automobile nissan
l'hybride deux fois par semaine un vrai
succès la corbeille est souvent vide en
fin de journée nous avons des retours
très positifs sur les employés sont très
contentes d'avoir non seulement accès
aux fruits gratuitement mais en plus ils
estiment participer à une action de
solidarité qui leur permet de faire acte
de don à une association qui s'occupe de
la recherche contre le cancer
j'en prends régulièrement lorsque je
suis au siège social en même temps que
mon café est bénéfique pour les
visiteurs également puisque quand je
suis visiteurs dans d'autres entreprises
clientes je profite également de ces
fruits frais clémentines raisins et
banane on n'a pas souvent le temps de
bien manger en entreprise on est
tellement chargé on a tellement de
choses à faire que c'est souvent la
solution de facilité d'aller prendre un
sandwich
de manger devant son ordinateur qu avoir
des fruits à disposition une entreprise
c'est une très bonne chose pour la
travailler mentation et pour être plus
efficace entre a créé il ya huit ans le
concept a fait des adeptes les vergers
de gally compte un millier de clients
sur paris et sa région votre démarche à
destination des salariés leur faciliter
la vie lorsqu'elles ont des enfants à
montigny le bretonneux une crèche
interentreprises a ouvert en février
dernier guillaume comme c'est johanna
boubekeur s'était rendu sur place pour
retrouver les parents mon tipi c'est la
quatrième crèche interentreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines
ouverte depuis le 2 janvier 2013 la
crèche du groupe people baby peut
accueillir 31 enfants âgés de 3 mois à 4
ans les enfants sont séparés en deux
sections petits moyens et moyens grands
mon tipi satisfait les enfants comme le
constate la mère de massés aux quatre
ans les beaucoup plus épanouie
on sent qu'il a envie de venir il fait
des choses il a des activités qui lui
sont proposés
c'est ce qui lui manquait en fait celle
déjà l'environnement il arrive c'est pas
une télé un canapé c'est des jeux c'est
un environnement adapté pour eux des
tables à leurs auteurs puis après voilà
il ya des activités ils font des
chapeaux pour un petit grain voilà on
leur propose du dessin de la peinture
c'est vraiment adapté pour eux mon tipi
à montigny le bretonneux est accessible
pour les parents employés chez banque
populaire val de france et du groupe
bouygues construction avec des horaires
flexibles 8 heures 19 heures la crèche
souhaite avoir des services supérieurs
aux crèches municipales larchitecture de
la crèche c'est très bien pensée on a un
matériel pédagogique
on est énormément gâtés et on
des professionnels diplômés ce qui n'est
pas le cas dans toutes les structures
dans toutes les crèches vous n'êtes pas
obligés d'habiter la commune pour avoir
une place votre seule contrainte avoue
finalement c'est que soit le papa soit
la maman fasse partie de passes partie
d'une entreprise qui réservent des
places et vous êtes sûr d'avoir votre
plasma de du tout-petit tâche du bébé
jusqu'à ce qu'ils partent à l'école et
ça c'est super parce que bon ben voilà
c'est ça rend très serein et l'enfant et
le parent bien sûr pour les parents le
tarif est le même que pour les crèches
municipales il varie de 87 centimes à
2,083 par heure selon les revenus et le
barème fixé par la caisse d'allocations
familiales couche soins et alimentation
bio tout est fourni
l'entreprise adhérente cotisent à la
hauteur du nombre de places réservées
le sport peut être aussi un moyen très
efficace pour installer une ambiance
détendue audureau je vous propose
d'aller à la rencontre de trois
collègues de travail qui se sont lancés
dans une aventure sportive un raid
interentreprises un reportage réalisé
avec jonathan vilma sofival et mélodies
l'occar siham chantal et antonin se
prépare pour une course sportive pas
comme les autres le trophée des
entreprises
ici les équipes sont formées de
collègues de travail et porte les
couleurs de leur société pour les trois
compétiteurs des maillots jaunes car
tout ce travail à la plateforme
industrielle courrier de bois d'arcy la
pique
mais aujourd'hui ils sont un peu plus
que le simple collègue le sport et
l'esprit d'équipé des as de la pi comme
ils se sont appelés prennent le pas sur
la hiérarchie j'aurais pas simple
stagiaire on est tous une équipe et on
est tous au même niveau en fait et on
est sportif
depuis quelques semaines les trois
collègues s'entraînent ensemble à la
course principalement mais d'autres
épreuves les attendent et 6ème compte
sur la complémentarité de l'équipe
tous les frais on est complètement
auditeurs envoie c'est tout à la
présentation en a une c'est plutôt le
vtt est long c'est plutôt le canoë
donc là je dirais que le seul forme on
n'est pas trop à l'aise c'est la trouve
ça qui est bon
chacun a pris l'eau mais ça devrait
aller qui dit compétition festive dit
échauffement festif
c'est en musique que se prépare aux
épreuves
les as de l'apix se prennent vite au jeu
à quelques minutes du début de la course
no stress
reste que la nouvelle et noir comptent
encore du travail je vais continuer
l'accord
après l'échauffement l'équipe retrouve
d'autres collègues venus participer au
raid
on tue le groupe la poste compte 10
équipes sur cette compétition
antonin 6 1 mais chantal son parti pour
près de sept kilomètres de course les as
de l'apic finiront 62e sur 63 mais
l'important était de participer
la course at elle vraiment changer
quelque chose dans leur relation pour le
savoir changement de décor nous
retrouvons les trois compétiteurs sur
leur lieu de travail
je suis siam la responsable
communication de la plateforme
industrielle courrier de bois d'arcy et
comme vous pouvez le voir dans la vie de
tous les jours je ne porte pas jogging
voilà donc je suis habillé pour mon
travail
alors moi ces chantages suis technicien
qualité sur la pique de bois d'arcy
je m'appelle en main je suis
actuellement en stage à la pique de bois
d'arcy j'ai troqué mon maillot jaune
pour mon gilet noir de la poste avec
quelques stages à son actif antonin
découvre le monde du travail
participer à des événements sportifs
entre collègues est une nouveauté pour
lui est un moyen de mieux s'intégrer
dans la société
on reparle de l'événement bas des
difficultés qu'on a rencontrés ou encore
bas c'est vrai que maintenant on en
rigole du coût de ces difficultés donc
c'est sympa aussi
et c'est vrai que ça crée pas une
cohésion de groupe que je bats que je
connaissais pas vu que ça faisait pas
longtemps que que j'étais dans
l'entreprise donc c'est vrai que ça
tisser quelques liens antonin et le
petit nouveau mais siam et chantal se
connaissent depuis trois ans à la base
simples collègues elles se sont
rapprochées il ya un an
en participant ensemble à la parisienne
6 km de course en portant les couleurs
de leur société depuis elle ne s'arrête
plus ces sorties du cas du travail
certaines font des entraînements
ensemble et danser si on va ensemble
c'est le soir après le boulot
donc on s'éclate aussi même aux
entraînements le sport un moyen de créer
du lien social et de renforcer le bien
être au bureau des notions de plus en
plus recherchée par les salariés pour
qu'ils travaillent doit rimer avec
plaisir quand j'ai change avec mes
collègues responsable communication
autre plateforme au niveau national on
voit quand même que il ya vraiment plus
de deux projets autour du sport du
bien-être des massages la nutrition
au-delà de cette politique interne le
groupe la poste est également sponsor de
grands événements sportifs notamment sur
le trophée des entreprises nous allons
maintenant découvrir trois entreprises
solidaires leurs activités sont très
différentes mais toutes trois sont des
entreprises d'insertion depuis
maintenant un mois jérôme et livreurs à
vélo au sein de l'association versailles
portage
chaque jour il assure les livraisons des
commerçants de la ville un service
gratuit pour les clients sur tous les
territoires de versailles grand parc
voilà d'accord on évalue cargo s'il vous
plaît
ce matin il doit porter des boissons à
une personne âgée sur versailles
première étape récupérer les bouteilles
commandé auprès du commerçant
ce caviste et uns des 85 adhérents de
l'association un service financé par les
commerçants avec une participation de la
ville et de l'état ça
quoi
merci à vue dont la livraison est prête
jérôme repart sur la route mais cette
association ne vise pas qu'à renforcer
le commerce de proximité et rendre
service aux personnes âgées ou
handicapées c'est aussi une entreprise
d'insertion
c'est aussi l'emploi des personnes
éloignées donc qui sont soit au chômage
soit qui ont eu des problèmes des
parcours difficiles
un divorce on peut se retrouver très
vite à la rue des personnes qui ont fait
un petit parcours en prison pour des des
petits débits et qui ont leur donne une
chance nous retrouvons jérôme qui
arrivent à destination
pour lui cet emploi signe la fin de deux
ans galère et pour chantal c'est un
service devenu indispensable
c'est très pratique ont commencé à élire
un petit peu c'est difficile pour nous
déporter les caisses de vin pack de
bouteilles donc c'est on trouve que
c'est vraiment très utile en 2012 près
de 2500 personnes ont fait appel à
l'association pour certaines personnes
isolées
la venue de jérôme ou d'un de ses
collègues est la seule visite de la
semaine
certaines personnes
ça fait des mois qu'ils restent chez eux
parce que bon soit réalisé place assez
lentement donc voilà ça nous permet de
il a livré
jérôme reprend la route il pourra
conserver ce travail deux ans au maximum
le temps de reprendre pied et de pédaler
vers d'autres horizons
depuis trois mois gérard travaille au
jardin de cocagne à magny les hameaux
une association d'insertion loi 1901 qui
cultive des légumes bio distribue chaque
semaine un des adhérents consommateurs
sous forme de paniers comme la plupart
de ses collègues gérard à intégrer les
jardins suite à une période de chômage
une manière de ne pas rester inactif
d'ailleurs retrouvé goût retrouvé des
personnes déjà avec ip je peux parler
discuter puis j'ai bien rigolé comme mes
collègues au fond derrière et puis c'est
super bien quoi c'est europan au goût au
travail pour certains les jardins c'est
également l'occasion d'envisager une
reconversion qui a travaillé pendant 12
ans dans les pompes funèbres du jour au
lendemain il s'est retrouvé sans travail
orientés par pôle emploi il a frappé à
la porte des jardins de cocagne en mars
2011 mme et découvert le métier qu'ils
souhaiteraient exercer marée chez moi
ici mon quotidien c'est travailler tous
les jours ici c'est super je change de
travail je vais des modes des modes de
terre que
de terreau que je sais déjà dans la
serre ici puis que je récolte en 2012
plusieurs personnes ont déjà récolté les
fruits de leur travail
quatre ont trouvé un emploi et de une
formation qualifiante
grâce au suivi de l'association gérard a
obtenu un entretien s'il est positif il
intégrera une enseigne de grande
distribution dans un mois quant à guy il
entame son deuxième cd des 2 6 mois au
jardin plus motivé que jamais pour faire
de sa nouvelle passion un métier
didier bonjour vous êtes directeur de
nouvelles attitudes une entreprise
spécialisée dans le recyclage de papier
de bureau
nous sommes d'ailleurs dans votre centre
de tri à coignières l'autre aspect de
votre entreprise c'est l'aspect social
vous avez été reconnue entreprise de
réinsertion
on a souhaité être entreprise
d'insertion pour justement accompagner
un peu les politiques de rse dont on
parle tant aujourd'hui
finalement si on prend les trois
économies l'économie du profit
l'économie sociale où l'économie
environnementale
aucune d'entre elles ne marchent bien
mais c'est la complémentarité de ses
économies aujourd'hui qui nous intéresse
beaucoup
et on pense que nous qui sommes accès à
la fois sur l'économie sociale qui est
vraiment notre raison d'être notre
boussole j'ai envie de dire notre nord
et l'économie environnementale par notre
activité de recyclage
on peut aujourd'hui trouver des systèmes
de coopération avec les entreprises du
secteur lucratif à juste titre pour être
encore plus performant dans toutes ses
activités
concrètement comment ça c'est des quines
vous proposer des formations
star fait des personnes un peu isolée du
chômage alors pour ce qu'on appelle les
parcours d'insertion c'est à dire des
gens éloignés de l'emploi qui viennent
chez nouvelle attitude
notre vocation c'est que sur une période
maximum de 24 mois on retrouve un emploi
pérenne aux personnes qui passent ici on
professionnalisme par ce qu'on appelle
les métiers de valoriste valorise
collecte qui vont chercher le papier les
entreprises et vallauris entrepôts comme
vous pouvez le voir par exemple en ce
moment quitterie qui conditionne et qui
prépare le papier ces métiers de
valorisation des matières premières
secondaires que l'on jette sont
aujourd'hui des métiers d'avenir et ils
permettent aussi de créer des
passerelles particulièrement efficace
sur ce qu'on appelle les éco industries
quand on sait collecter et recycler
préparait le papier on sait le faire
bros plastique on sait faire preuve
carton etc
donc on pense que c'est vraiment des
métiers d'avenir quand on accueille un
candidat notre entreprise
on les fait suivre un parcours spécial
pendant quatre mois finalement regarde
comment le candidat travail se
comportent respecte les instructions de
sécurité etc puis ensuite pendant huit
mois
on va avec des chargés d'insertion des
personnels spécialisés définir avec lui
leur parcours professionnel et amener
des formations qualifiantes qui vont
vers ce parcours professionnel et notre
dernière mission qui est la plus
importante quelque part c'est de faire
des passerelles vers l'emploi donc vers
les entreprises du secteur économique
globale et c'est là où on a des tas de
choses à se dire encore sur saint
quentin en yvelines
au-delà de cet aspect environnemental et
social le troisième volet c'est l'aspect
économique
ce que vous n'oubliez pas et finalement
d'être concurrentiels et votre
entreprise fonctionne très bien
95 % de notre chiffre d'affaires c'est
nous qui allons chercher donc c'est nous
qui allons chercher nos clients à qui on
propose des programmes de recyclage des
opérations d archivage des opérations de
destruction confidentiel donc
effectivement la condition de réussite
tout ça c'est d'être de bons
entrepreneurs sociaux dans notre domaine
d'activité principal et c'est ce qu'on
essaie de prouver tous les jours
merci beaucoup pour finir cette séquence
sur le bien-être en entreprise
je vous propose de découvrir le portrait
de véronique à chexbres peintre sur
porcelaine et meilleur ouvrier de france
son métier et sa passion et c'est bien
là la clé pour que le travail soit un
plaisir un reportage signé patrick et
jacques de dixmude et catherine plateau
un dessin presque une photo sur
porcelaine un sens du détail ine
véronique avec vient de décrocher le
diplôme de meilleur ouvrier de france
ce qui a changé c'est j'ai mené j'ai
plus loin de faire d'erreur modeste
veronica bat grain elle a démarré la
peinture sur porcelaine un peu par
hasard dit elle d'abord diplômé d'un bac
arts déco la versaillaise s'est orienté
vers un tout autre métier
éducatrice de jeunes enfants sans perdre
de vue sa première passion et ce qu'il
avait séduit dès le départ
le côté de décors d'objets donner une
âme un objet il y avait aussi la partie
un peu technique a dépassé
des plus grandes difficultés au
démarrage
parce que quand on prépare mal sa
peinture ça petit cahier alors ça rend
pas ce qu'on veut les des couleurs qui
se mangent les autres quand on travaille
les l'or les métaux précieux
c'est une chose avec des cuissons
différentes mais il ya vraiment une
somme de connaissances à revoir
de loisirs véronique ans l'a fait un
métier le métier très prenant je ne
compte pas mes heures la pièce de
concours à clé là ça se passe j'ai mis
plus de 250 heures sans compter tout le
travail d' approche en fait savoir ce
que j'allais faire
j'ai passé deux mois dessus avant de me
lancer sur la pièce m pour remporter le
concours de meilleur ouvrier de france
qui se déroule tous les quatre ans et
veronica baiguera travailler sur ce vase
et cette assiette un travail alors à la
frise avec des personnages et des
paysages un savoir faire complet c'est
contente que ce ça me permet de dire où
on joue c'est un monde où vous pour
cette fin d'émission nous allons
rencontrer des étudiants qui travaillent
cet été ils ont trouvé des emplois peu
classique que ce soit dans le lieu de
travail ou dans l'activité des images
des lots diwan et jonathan vilma
fini les cours pour les dix neuf mille
étudiants évinois les vacances ont
commencé les dévora n'est pas dans ce
camping pour camper ali a décroché un
job d'été pendant deux mois
cette étudiante en médecine travail pour
le bar restaurant un emploi saisonnier
classique dans un lieu assez original on
ne compte que 16 camping dans le
département de quoi concilier impératifs
financiers et plaisir je passe l'été
pour gagner 4 souhait de pouvoir tenir
mieux l'année que quand on marque man
que ce serait qu'on peut pas trop beau
c'est à côté
quand on fait médecine donc c'est de
cumuler les avants alicia à l'accueil a
de son côté fini son cursus
universitaire cette année pendant 6 ans
tous les étés elle a enchaîné les
emplois saisonniers
cette bretonne a été serveuse garde
nationale et à travailler à bord de
ferries sur la manche
ces expériences lui ont permis de
trouver sa voie professionnelle
après quelques saisons elle a stoppé ses
études de droit pour se reconvertir dans
le tourisme tu as travaillé sur un
bateau je me suis demandé qu'est ce que
j'avais fait en fait dans le droit j'ai
adoré mes études mais je me suis rendu
compte que ce n'était pas ce que je
voulais faire
donc j'ai trouvé ma place en fait dans
le tourisme et grâce à mon boulot d'été
qui m'a un peu décalée de diderot
achevant reza dans ce camping dix
saisonniers ont été recrutés en renfort
pour l'été avec 70% du chiffre
d'affaires réalisé sur cette période
on ne compte que cinq permanents mais
ces derniers ont souvent commencé ici
avec un job d'été on renouvelle beaucoup
de notre public saisonniers on a la
chance d'avoir plusieurs campings donc
de pouvoir leur proposer une mobilité
sur les années donc on peut travailler à
versailles une seconde année dans le sud
de la france au bord de la mer et
ensuite lorsqu'ils sont en fin d'études
on propose régulièrement à a
à nos saisonniers de rester avec nous de
continuer l'aventuré avec nous
évidemment d'évoluer avec nous on a
beaucoup de responsables de campings qui
ont commencé comme étant des des
personnels saisonniers au restaurant ou
à l'accueil ou à l'entretien du terrain
autres lieux touristiques les parcs
d'attractions au milieu des badauds et
des vacanciers en terrasse amélie ni
entame sa quatrième saison
auparavant à l'accueil elle découvre
cette année la restauration par la
caisse dans les supermarchés ce n'était
pas facile top que ça donc ici il faut
que j'avais un jeu mais bien en venant
en tant que cliente
on voit un peu l'univers et après voir
l'envers du décor aussi c'est
intéressant
chaque année deux cent mille personnes
foulent les allées de ce parc face à
cette masse de visiteurs les saisonniers
d'été apprennent sur le tas comme au
camping de versailles al embauche on
privilégie la qualité de l'accueil et le
sourire plutôt qu'une formation
diplômante
ces jeunes représentent souvent un vent
de fraîcheur les saisonniers qui
arrivent pour juillet-août il redonne
aussi un petit coup de fouet à ce qui
laisse on a depuis plusieurs mois il ya
du sang neuf qui arrive ça redynamise
les équipes il ya un petit peu de
concurrence qui s'installe donc c'est un
bienfait pour les gens qui sont là
depuis le début de l'année d'accueillir
des nouveaux une deuxième équipe qui
arrive et qui redonne un petit coup de
souffle à l'équipe qui est là depuis
quatre cinq mois selon l'observatoire de
la vie étudiante en 2010 23 % des
étudiants travaillent qualité
et si jobs d'été rimer avec solidarité
chaque année le conseil général recruté
150 étudiants pour rompre l'isolément
des personnes âgées
le principe est simple les jeunes bonne
de leur camp en juillet en août pour
leur tenir compagnie ou les aider dans
leurs tâches quotidiennes
cette année c'est la dixième édition on
a rencontré deux étudiantes et une
personne âgée qui participent à ces
dispositifs
suivez moi donc nous voici chez
marguerite le dren bonjour bonsoir moi
et tous les étés vous recevez des
étudiants qui viennent vous rendre
visite
exactement cet été ce sera que les liens
oui mais en premier pour la première
fois une rose vous faisiez partie des
étudiants qui venait rendre visite à
marguerittes
l'année dernière vous comment vous avez
connu ce dispositif
quand vous êtes venu à postuler alors en
fait j'ai réalisé un stage à l'hôpital
de au tendon qui est juste à côté de la
coordination gérontologique l'année
dernière et du coup j'ai connu ce
dispositif dans ce cadre là qu'est ce
qui vous a intéressé
pourquoi avoir voulu postuler à ce
disque alors vas tu réalises une
formation d'assistant de service social
et du coup on est sensibilisé aller
seulement des personnes âgées l'été donc
je voulais participer à ce dispositif
pour pouvoir lutter contre l'isolément
des personnes âgées quand les familles
partent en vacances pendant le mois de
juillet août
l'été c'est plus difficile d'avoir des
proches qui viennent nous rendre visite
ou avec les vacances c'est plus espacées
je n'ai pas beaucoup de contacts
non c'est les seules visites que j'ai ce
sont les eps de
ménagères et puis ce que j'apprécie
beaucoup
c'est l'été que j'attende beaucoup avec
impatience du coup vous allez retrouver
marguerite cet été tout le mois de
juillet oui je vais devoir vous
supportez oui vous avez déjà prévu des
choses ou alors vous êtes apte et à
chaque fois en fonction des personnes on
s'adapte toujours en fonction des
personnes en fait ça dépend de ce que
elle préfère faire on s'adapte ouais
tout le monde est différent et justement
c'est ça qu'est qui permet aucune
journée sont pareils on fait qu'est-ce
que ça vous apporte concrètement
bah ça apporte un sentiment de gta pas
fierté mais on est heureux de pouvoir
aider et de pouvoir rendre heureuse
certaines personnes qu'ils méritent et
qui sont isolées par exemple et rose de
la même façon mais qu'est ce que ça vous
a apporté donc au quotidien c'était
surtout tenir compagnie finalement
marguerie que ça tenir compagnie voilà
qui je société des phosphates pour se
divertir et surtout va se sentir utile
et pouvoir aider les autres
pendant les vacances quoi parce que vous
m'indiquiez vous avez gardé contact avec
certains étudiants je ne me souviens pas
du prénom qui m'a dressé une carte pour
le premier de l'an mondial sûr que ça
m'a vous êtes touché un oui très bien
merci beaucoup à tous les trois mois je
vous en prie on vous souhaite du coup en
bois n'était clélia retrouve marguerite
cet été
rose quant à elle se rend dans des coins
plus isolé à bord d'un véhicule
spécialisé comme ces deux étudiantes 150
jeunes participent à ce dispositif
yveline étudiants seniors un roulement
est établi chaque jeune travail un mois
sur l'été ils passeront chaque jour 4
visite à des personnes âgées isolées
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous souhaite un
très bon été sur tv fil 78